-Welcome back to "Late Night."
It is almost Halloween,
and here to talk about it
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin.
-Hi, Seth. Hi! Hi!
You know what?
It's finally Halloween.
Yay! Halloween is one
of my favorite holidays.
-You know, I have to say, Amber,
I've known you for a while,
and you don't seem
like the Halloween type.
-No, baby, I love Halloween.
Do you want to know why?
-Why?
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
-♪ The leaves start falling
from the trees ♪
♪ It's time to come inside ♪
♪ Grab a big warm cup of cocoa ♪
♪ 'Cause you're in
for quite a ride ♪
♪ The stars have all aligned ♪
♪ And you don't want
to miss this ♪
♪ Halloween's my favorite time ♪
♪ 'Cause Halloween
is Christmas ♪
-What?
-Halloween is
the official beginning
of the Christmas season!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, no.
It's not.
-Yes, it is!
-No, we still have
two more months.
-Everybody knows Christmas
begins on Halloween,
and it doesn't end until
Martin Luther King Day.
-Absolutely not.
-It's already here, Seth.
Morning shows are starting
to do Christmas segments.
Christmas sales have started.
And with supply chain issues,
if you didn't order your
Christmas presents yesterday,
it's already too late.
-We still have Halloween,
Daylight Savings,
Thanksgiving,
and then Christmas.
Every year they start this stuff
earlier and earlier.
And it's bad enough when it's
like a month early,
but two months early?
I will not tolerate this.
I asked you out here to sing a
Halloween song, and you agreed.
Agreed?
-Okay, agreed.
♪ Oh, whoa ♪
♪ Soon Santa's gonna show ♪
♪ He'll scurry down my chimney ♪
♪ October 'neath the mistletoe ♪
♪ Is where I'm gonna be ♪
♪ Halloween's for spending time
with loved ones ♪
♪ And it's bliss ♪
♪ Halloween's my favorite time ♪
♪ 'Cause Halloween
is Christmas ♪
-What you're saying
is impossible.
Christmas is only one day,
and it's not October 31st.
-Christmas is not a day.
It's a whole season
like Hot Girl Summer.
-Amber, every time you say this,
it makes me angrier.
I cannot believe
you're one of those people
who starts Christmas
way too early.
-I honestly feel like
this is something
you could have
just assumed about me.
-You're right.
-I am right!
-No! I mean you're right
about me being able to assume
that you're a Christmas freak,
not that you're right about
Halloween being Christmas.
You're very, very wrong
about that.
I am putting my foot down.
I asked you out here
to sing a Halloween song.
Agreed?
-Agreed!
-I am a little worried
that your line is off-camera
and that when we
cut back to you...
-♪ Oh, whoa ♪
♪ It's Halloween, so naturally ♪
♪ I got Christmas on the brain ♪
♪ Come trick-or-treating
at my house ♪
♪ And you'll get a candy cane ♪
♪ I don't give a rip if all this
puts me on your [bleep] list ♪
♪ Halloween's my favorite time ♪
Say "why," Seth.
-No.
-♪ Halloween's
my favorite time ♪
Eh?
♪ Halloween's my favorite time ♪
-Alright.
-♪ 'Cause Halloween
is Christmas ♪
It's Christmas!
Merry Christmas!
-Get out of here.
You get out of here.
Your charm does not work on me.
Amber Ruffin, everybody.
We'll be right back
with Amanda Seyfried.
-It's Christmas now.
It's Christmas!